Es geht um das Recht von Staatsbürger*innen,
ihre Religionsfreiheit
ausleben zu dürfen. In dem Moment-
-Können sie doch
-Kann ich nicht!
Nur nicht als Lehrerin.
-Nur nicht als Lehrerin und nicht als Richterin, als Kassiererin, als Erzieherin
im Beruf. Wo soll ich noch arbeiten?
13 Fragen. Hier kommt Frage Nummer 1: Sollen
religiöse Symbole in öffentlichen
Einrichtungen verboten werden? Ja
oder nein? Wenn ihr sagt Ja,
Religion muss Privatsache bleiben, dann bitte
auf dem grünen Feld positionieren. Und wenn ihr sagt
Nee, nee, Moment, wir haben
in Deutschland Religionsfreiheit,
dann bitte auf dem gelben Feld. Und Bitteschön!
Ja, vielen Dank! Jetzt wissen wir, wo ihr steht.
Aber wo steht ihr? Kopftuch,
Kreuz oder Kippa? Haben in öffentlichen
Einrichtungen nichts verloren, sagen
die einen, denn Religion muss
Privatsache bleiben. Das gilt für Schule,
Gerichtssäle oder auch für die Polizei.
Ja, Moment, sagen die anderen.
In Deutschland herrscht ja aus gutem
Grund Religionsfreiheit. Verbote würden
diese einschränken und zudem die Gläubigen
diskriminieren, zum Beispiel
am Arbeitsplatz. Solche Fälle landen
in letzter Zeit immer häufiger vor höchsten
Gerichten, zuletzt beim
Europäischen Gerichtshof. Das zeigt zwei Dinge.
Erstens Die Sache ist juristisch
gesehen verdammt knifflig. Und zweitens
Diese Gesellschaft ist sich ganz
offenbar uneins, wie sie mit Religion
in der Öffentlichkeit umgehen will.
Uneins sind sich heute auch meine Gäste. Aber
bei 13 Fragen geht es ja um den Kompromiss.
Der ist bei dieser Frage
ein bisschen schwierig. Und trotzdem
habe ich die Hoffnung, dass wir trotzdem zeigen
können, wie wir vielleicht ein bisschen
näher aufeinander zugehen können.
Ob das heute klappt? Schauen wir mal.
Aber erst mal die Frage an euch: Wo würdet
ihr euch positionieren? Auf der grünen
Seite? Religion muss Privatsache bleiben!
Oder auf der gelben: Nein,
Religionsfreiheit muss durchgesetzt
werden. Die Regeln sind ganz einfach.
Wenn ihr der Gegenseite in irgendeinem Punkt
zustimmt, dann dürft ihr gerne
einen Schritt nach vorne kommen, das heißt
auf die Gegenseite zugehen. Und wenn ihr sagt:
Eigentlich finde ich deine Meinung
gar nicht so schlecht, aber da erzählst
du gerade großen Mist. Dann könnt
ihr auch einen Schritt zurückgehen,
also euch entfernen von der Gegenseite.
Mein Ziel ist es natürlich, euch
möglichst nah in die Mitte zu bringen, hier
in dieses sogenannte Kompromissfeld.
Mal sehen, ob das dann am Ende dieser Folge
auch klappt. 13 Fragen. Hier kommt Frage
2 und die geht an Rabia. Du studierst Jura,
du bist gläubige Muslima und du
hast Sorge, dass auch was deinen Beruf
anbelangt, dein Kopftuch ein "Problem",
in Anführungszeichen, werden könnte,
nämlich inwiefern?
-Anfang Mai wurde
ein Gesetz beschlossen, das neue
Beamt*innen Gesetz, das dazu verleiten
könnte, dass jetzt mir der Beamtenstatus verwehrt
wird. Wir haben jetzt aber auch 2020
eine Entscheidung gehabt von einer
Rechts-Referendarin aus Hessen, der bestimmte
Bereiche im Referendariat, wenn sie halt
auf der Richterbank sitzen würde oder bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
Aufgaben übernehmen würde
dass die Gefahr
bestünde, dass da eine Gefahr
für die Neutralität der Justiz
wäre. Und auch da sehen wir das Argument:
Ja, vor Gericht wüsste man ja
nicht der, ob der Verfahrensbeteiligte,
ob die Richterin jetzt nach der Rechtsordnung
urteilen würde
oder dass sie nicht neutral ist.
Religiöse Symbole sind für mich Teil von Identität.
Ich finde, es ist sehr wichtig, dass wir die Identitäten
unserer Mitbürger*innen
sehen können, gerade dann, wenn diese Identitäten
durch unser Grundgesetz
geschützt sind. Ich würde gerne
wissen, warum wir in diesem Land seit 20 Jahren
durch Gerichtsentscheidungen
versuchen, Wege zu finden, wie wir das Kopftuch
einschränken oder gar verbieten können
und dadurch Frauen vom Arbeitsmarkt abhalten.
Könnt ihr nachvollziehen, Rabia, aus Angst,
dass sie sagt: Moment mal, ich bin
ja nun mal gläubig. Das ist nun mal
so. Dass sie dann Angst hat, quasi eine Art
Berufsverbot auferlegt zu bekommen.
Ich kann das verstehen und das wird
auch ein Punkt sein, bei dem ich früher
oder später mich zumindest vorsichtig
in das nächste Feld wage, weil ich mir
gut vorstellen kann, wie es sich anfühlt,
als Anhängerin einer Religion
von bestimmten Berufen ausgeschlossen
zu werden. In einem Land, in dem Kirchen
hofiert werden. Das ist nämlich
das eigentliche Problem. Und deswegen mache
ich jetzt einfach schon mal
diesen Schritt und sage: Ich bin
total bei dir. Wenn du nicht verstehst,
warum in Bezug auf den Islam, auf deine Religion,
staatliche Neutralität gefordert
wird, wohingegen die Kirchen aus Steuergeldern
subventioniert werden,
so nicht nur aus der Kirchensteuer,
bei weitem nicht, die Kirchen eigene Gesetze
haben und, beispielsweise was das Arbeitsrecht
angeht, also ein perfekt
treffender Bereich, und diese Kirchen
von vorne bis hinten mit der Politik in bester
Lobbyarbeit zusammenarbeiten. Ich finde,
dass religiöse Symbole an staatlichen
Institutionen deswegen nichts
verloren haben, weil der Staat seiner Pflicht
zur Neutralität, zur weltanschaulichen
Neutralität nachkommen muss. Und er ist
eigentlich so etwas wie ein unparteiischer
Schiedsrichter auf dem Markt
der Weltanschauungen. Und es ist
ja richtig, deine Religionsfreiheit wird
tatsächlich ein kleines Stückchen
eingeschränkt. Aber ich denke, das ist
zumutbar, denn jedes Freiheitsrecht
endet dort, wo die Freiheiten anderer beginnen
und Rechte müssen immer miteinander
abgewogen werden. Und ich bin ganz fest
der Überzeugung, dass das staatliche
staatliche Neutralitätsgebot schwerer
wiegt als dein religiös
motivierter Wunsch, auch während der Arbeit
als Richterin, Lehrerin oder Polizistin
dein Kopftuch zu tragen. Also erstens
glaube ich.. Also erstmal danke für deine Offenheit
und zweitens also A) wird ihre religiöse
Freiheit nicht ein kleines
bisschen beschränkt, sondern ist ziemlich
ein massiver Eingriff. Und die zweite
Frage ist ja auch noch: Warum eigentlich?
Was gibt es für eine massive
Begründung, etwas so stark einzuschränken, wo weder
eine Gefahr droht, noch eine Manipulation
im Raume steht? Ein Verbot von religiösen
Symbolen an staatlichen
Organisationen und staatlichen Institutionen muss
deswegen diskutiert werden, weil es ist
eine Frage der Grundrechte. Es ist
gleichzeitig auch eine Frage dessen,
in welchem Klima wir leben wollen. Ich fasse
das mal kurz zusammen: Wenn Rabia jetzt,
mal angenommen, sie wollte Richterin werden,
sie könnte die neutralste, objektivste oder
beste Richterin aller Zeiten sein,
darf aber ihren Beruf vielleicht
nicht ausüben, weil sie eben gläubig ist.
Doch, darf sie schon. Also ist
denn hier wirklich die Religionsfreiheit
eingeschränkt? Es ist doch das Symbol,
dass, sagen wir es ganz ehrlich,
das Kopftuch, ist es doch, was das eigentliche
Symbol ist, was als Religionssymbol
nicht gezeigt werden soll. Es sollen
keine religiösen Symbole gezeigt
werden, dass Kreuz auch nicht,
bei mir in der Schule beispielsweise
und auch nicht die Kippa. Nun ist für mich
die Frage ist denn das das einzige Zeichen
deine Religion nach außen zu zeigen?
Ich kenne sicherlich auch gläubige Frauen,
die kein Kopftuch tragen und trotzdem
den Glauben haben, also den Menschen,
die darauf bestehen, religiöse Symbole
in der öffentlichen, im öffentlichen Raum
der Schule zu zeigen. Muss ich entgegnen,
dass die Schule dafür nicht den Raum
bieten kann, sondern wir sind
wirklich ein neutraler Ort und religiöse Symbole,
und auch das Werben um Religion
gehört nicht in den Raum, den öffentlichen Raum einer Schule.
Die Frage ist doch die: Das Tragen
des Kopftuchs ist durch Artikel 4
geschützt. Und jetzt zu sagen Wir haben
Musliminnen, die tragen das nicht
oder wir haben doch andere Muslime,
die tragen es halt und die, die es tragen:
Pustekuchen! Die dürfen halt in dem Bereich nicht
arbeiten. Und es geht gar nicht darum,
dass ich nicht neutral handele. Es geht
um die Zuschreibung meiner Handlung. Und das finde
ich halt schwierig. Wenn wir das nämlich
durchgehen lassen,
dass aufgrund der Zuschreibung,
Menschen Berufe nicht mehr ausüben dürfen
und Gesetze erlassen werden. Da würden
wir in anderen Bereichen, gerade
auch in der Justiz und Verwaltung
gehörig Probleme bekommen. Aber Daniels Argument
war ja, es gibt keinen
Anfangsverdacht. Warum sollte ich denn überhaupt,
wenn jemand ein religiöses Bekenntnis
in die Öffentlichkeit trägt, davon ausgehen,
dass er eventuell nicht neutral sein könnte?
Aber ich gehe gar nicht davon aus,
dass wir nicht neutral ist. Ich gehe
davon aus, dass die Person, die also
wenn wir jetzt vor Gericht sind oder wenn wir in der Schule
sind, dass es eher
den Schutzbedürftigen, dass es denen eher erschwert
wird. Gerade Mädchen und Frauen,
die vielleicht aus fundamentalistischen
Familien kommen, Gemeinschaften kommen.
Wie sollen die es raus schaffen,
wenn sie überall religiöse Symbole sehen?
Die Trennung zwischen Religion und Staat
ist insbesondere wichtig für LGBTs,
Mädchen und Frauen, die entweder auf dem Weg
sind, sich
aus einer fundamentalistischen
Familienstruktur zu befreien
oder die es schon geschafft haben und sich
in einem neutralen Staat viel vertretener
fühlen können. Also wenn wir überlegen: Die Evangelikalen
werden in Deutschland immer
größer. In Bayern hängen an Schulen
Kruzifixe. Wie ist das für eine Person?
Obwohl Bayern ist katholisch, aber wie ist das für eine Person,
die es eigentlich da raus
schaffen will, immer wieder diese Symbole
zu sehen? Und...
-Fragen wir doch mal
den Mann, der für das Kreuz steht und auch gerne
das Kreuz in öffentlichen Räumen
hat. Richtig?
-Ja doch, genau. Ich freue
mich darüber. Und erstens: Bayern ist nicht
katholisch. Südlich vielleicht.
Er kommt aus Franken. Das zählt nicht
zu Bayern. So richtig. Das ist evangelisch
natürlich. Aber da ich ich kann es nicht
ganz nachvollziehen, weil es da so
viele... Du sagst, sie kann ja ein Teilbereich
von dem, was sie ohne Kopftuch
möglich wäre, trotzdem machen. Aber halt nicht
alles. Und ich fühle mich da an die DDR
erinnert, wo mir viele Christinnen
erzählen: Ich durfte nicht studieren, ich durfte kein
Lehrer werden, nicht weil ich was nach außen
getragen habe, sondern weil sie wussten,
dass ich sonntags in die Kirche gehe
und im Kirchenvorstand bin. Und davor
warne ich. Also warum soll man
das eingrenzen? Warum kommt diese Vor-Vermutung,
dass jemand, der ja nicht
weil er jemanden übernehmen
will, ein religiöses Symbol trägt,
sondern weil es halt zu ihm gehört.
Religiöse Symbole sollten in staatlichen
Institutionen nicht verboten
werden, gerade nicht im persönlichen Bereich,
denn es macht den Menschen als Ganzes
aus. Nicht nur das wir scheinen und das,
was er tut, sondern auch die spirituelle,
geistliche Seite, das was er glaubt.
Aber das Argument war ja: Sie redet ja
nicht über dich als Person, sondern über
diejenigen, die sich damit
auseinandersetzen müssen, dass du
zum Beispiel ein riesen Kreuz um den Hals
trägst, beispielsweise. Und sie sagt:
Eventuell gibt es dann
Gruppen, die da vielleicht immer wieder neu
traumatisiert werden, weil sie zum Beispiel
aus fundamentalen Gruppen kommen.
Denen würde man das Leben ja
leichter machen. Das ist ja eine Güterabwägung
zwischen deinen, deinen Rechten und den Rechten
der Leute, die sich vielleicht
diskriminiert fühlen vom Kreuz.
-Also ich bin einen Schritt vorgegangen,
weil ich das schon nicht uninteressant
fand und weil ich das auch nachvollziehen
kann. Weil es tatsächlich auch so
ist, dass ich die implizierte Problematik
mit starken religiösen Symbolen
natürlich auch von der orthodoxen Seite,
von der fundamentalistischen Seite her
kenne. Auch im Judentum. Es gibt natürlich
eine extreme Beengung und eine Eingrenzung
von Freiheiten in Familien,
von Frauenrechten, von jede Menge
Sachen, die einhergehen mit einer religiösen
Symbolik. Das ist richtig. Und trotzdem
ist es natürlich unverschämt. Ihr sagt
ja: Du kannst doch einen
anderen Beruf wählen, werd doch irgendwie
eine nichtstaatliche Anwältin.
Muss ja nicht Richterin werden. Was ist,
wenn sie Richterin werden will, weil es ihr Traum
ist? Das ist doch niemandes
Recht, aufgrund dessen so
zu sagen, wie sie sich verhalten muss.
Und wie gesagt, was steht denn
dem entgegen? Was ist denn überhaupt
das Problem dessen, dass man ein Kopftuch
trägt?
-Das würde ich gerne direkt beantworten.
Du hast vorhin von dem Anfangsverdacht
gesprochen. Ja,
dieser Anfangsverdacht gilt nicht
den Trägern und Trägerinnen der religiösen
Symbole, sondern sie gilt der Religion.
Und die ist extrem gut begründbar.
Du sprichst von der DDR, da reden wir von den letzten
15-60 Jahren. Wir können
uns die vorherigen Jahrhunderte
anschauen, was mit Menschen gemacht wurden, die sich
nicht zum Christentum bekannt haben.
Wir können heute in islamisch-regierte Länder
schauen und uns anschauen, was mit Menschen
gemacht wird, die sich nicht
zum Islam und seinen Werten bekennen.
Die werden gesteinigt, werden öffentlich
geköpft. Das war im Christentum lange
Zeit nichts anderes. Das orthodoxe Judentum
erfüllt das genauso. Und hier
ist der Anfangsverdacht, der ist nicht
nur ein Anfangsverdacht, sondern es lässt
sich ganz klar zeigen, dass das heutige
Bildungssystem und Rechtssystem,
davon sprechen wir heute, nur deswegen so gut
funktioniert und uns eine freie und offene
Gesellschaft beschert, weil wir uns
in Jahrhunderten von der Religion
emanzipiert haben. Und heute exakt
diese Symbole wieder genau da rein
zu holen, wäre kontraproduktiv.
Und deswegen gehe ich auch wieder
einen kleinen Schritt zurück.
-Das bedeutet ja,
wenn man deine deine Argumentation
jetzt konsequent weiterverfolgt, dann bist du ja
nicht dagegen, dass religiöse
Symbole in der Öffentlichkeit gezeigt werden,
sondern du bist gegen Religion
an sich.
-Nein, ich halte Religion
für eine in dem Fall vollkommen
unproblematische Privatsache, wo religiöse
Menschen eben keine übergriffigen
Tätigkeiten ausüben, die andere in ihren
Rechten einschränken. Aber ich halte
es für schwer problematisch,
religiöse Überzeugungen in liberal-
rechtsstaatliche Systeme einzuführen.
Damit kommt der Clash.
-Damit hast du es zumindest geschafft, dass hier Bewegung
auf das Spielfeld war. Die gab es vorher
auch schon, bei Carina nämlich. Das habe
ich vorhin aus dem Augenwinkel schon
gesehen. Du bist auch nach vorne gegangen,
als Daniel gerade gesprochen hat,
nämlich. Warum? Ich bin sehr für gegenseitige
Toleranz, für, ich bin ehrlich gesagt
auch für Neutralität. Und ich bin, ich komme
aus dem Bereich Schule und ich finde je
jünger, die Kinder sind, umso deutlicher
muss der Erwachsene, der vor ihnen
steht, neutral und offen sein. Und wenn man
da ganz deutlich mit einem Kopftuch
ist, dann ist man nicht neutral. Nach außen hin
ist man zuerst einmal nicht
neutral. Ich will das nicht werten und nicht
verurteilen, aber es ist einfach
nicht neutral.
-Entschuldigung, wenn er Mitglied der CDU ist,
ist er auch nicht neutral oder von der AfD.
-Ja, aber das trägt er nicht auf dem T-Shirt.
Neutralität ist doch ein absolutes Illusionsphantom.
-Nein, das stimmt nicht.
-Nein, das gibt es nicht.
Das kann man versuchen rechtlich
zu fassen, aber da nicht. Da ist
der Unterschied natürlich: Es darf sich
niemand hinstellen und sagen" Guten
Tag, ich bin hier von der CDU, ich bin jetzt
neuer Lehrer und Lehrer." Oder ich trage ein CDU T-Shirt, ist auch verboten.
Aber was ist, wenn ich als Lehrer ein T-Shirt
tragen möchte gegen Nazis? Es geht
ja nicht nur um Säkularität,
sondern auch um weltanschauliche
Neutralität. Also es gibt ja auch Lehrer,
die "Atomkraft, nein danke!"-T-Shirts
tragen oder "Scheiß Nazis!"-T-Shirts tragen.
Und ich finde das gehört genauso
wenig in die Schule. Natürlich ist Neutralität
irgendwie ein Hirngespinst. Also
wir können nicht gänzlich neutral sein,
wir sind immer noch nicht da, wir sind
immer noch Individuen.
-Es geht auch nicht.
-Es geht um's Zeigen!
-Was?
-Mir geht es nur darum, sich wenigstens
zu bemühen, Neutralität darzustellen, also keine Symbole zu tragen.
-Aber Rabia,
kannst du das nachvollziehen?
Jetzt hat Fatma gerade gesagt, wenigstens
das Bemühen um Neutralität sollte
durchaus auch sichtbar sein.
-Ich kann den Wunsch
verstehen, aber letztendlich die Konsequenz
von diesem reinen Bemühen wäre
der Verzicht auf mein Recht. Das Tragen
des Kopftuchs ist durch Artikel 4
geschützt. Punkt. Und sobald
wir in unseren staatlichen Institutionen
Neutralität propagieren, aber
dadurch Leute ausschließen. Dann sind wir nicht
mehr neutral. Ich finde, staatliche
Institutionen müssen gerade die Vielfalt
der Bevölkerung widerspiegeln. Dass wir von diesem gesellschaftlichen
Diskurs
haben, dadurch ermöglichen wir ja
Dass, dass wir ein Miteinander entwickeln
können. Anders geht es doch nicht.
Und wie sollen wir dann funktionieren,
wenn wir einander ausschließen?
Selbst wenn man im Gericht dann das Problem
hätte. Okay, die Richterin, der Richter
wirkt befangen, kann ich ja einen
Befangenheitsantrag stellen.
Und ich vermisse in der Debatte,
dass wir auf diese Rechtsinstrumente, die wir schon haben.
Das wir nicht
darauf verweisen und die bestärken,
weil dadurch, indem wir sie nicht betonen,
dass wir einen Befangenheitsantrag
haben, den Straftatbestand der Rechtsbeugung,
höhlen wir unser System aus. Dadurch
will man diese Instrumente einfach schwächer.
Ich bin vor allen Dingen deswegen einen
ganz großen Schritt nach vorne gegangen
und habe mich jetzt auch noch weiter
in diese Richtung Kompromissfeld bewegt,
Weil mir sehr deutlich auffällt,
dass du die ganze Zeit, ganz weit hinten
an der Ursprungslinie stehst. Vielleicht
ist das nicht deine Absicht, aber ich habe
ein bisschen den Eindruck und das ist
leider der Eindruck, den ich öfter habe,
wenn ich mit Vertreterinnen und Vertretern
von Religionen diskutiere,
dass die Kompromissbereitschaft
relativ gering ist. So, und das stört mich.
Ich verstehe, dass du dich als Muslima,
die sich dazu verpflichtet fühlt,
ein Kopftuch zu tragen, auch während der Arbeit
ausgegrenzt und diskriminiert
fühlst. Aber ich würde fast sagen, es tut
mir leid, wenn ich diesen militärischen
Begriff hier anbringe. Das ist
eine Art Kollateralschaden, um den Staat
vor dem Zugriff durch die Religion
zu schützen. Und das, denke ich, müssen
wir in Kauf nehmen, wenn wir diese offene,
freie Gesellschaft schützen wollen.
Darf ich einen Kompromissvorschlag
machen?
-Jetzt schon? Ja, gerne.
-So, wenn wir sagen
würden, dass wir einen säkularen
Staat haben, der sich verpflichtet, zu jeder
Religion gleich fremd zu sein..
-Bin ich noch weiter vorne.
-Dann sind wir in unserem
aktuellen System. Das ist unser Staat.
Aber was ist die Konsequenz aus deinem
Kompromissvorschlag? Du bist jetzt
nach vorne gegangen, aber ich habe das jetzt,
also was, was folgt daraus?
-Was folgt daraus ist, dass wir eine Prämisse
gefunden haben, auf die wir uns beide
einigen können. Okay, das heißt aber,
das hat jetzt nichts mit dir
und deinem Kopftuch im Gerichtssaal zu tun?
Nein.
-Okay, jetzt Carina, vielleicht kannst du noch mal kurz
auf den Punkt bringen: Warum dürfen an deiner
Schule Lehrer und Lehrerinnen keine
religiösen Symbole öffentlich tragen?
-Also ich habe sehr junge Kinder und die werden
eingeschult bei mir. Da sind sie fünf,
sechs Jahre. Und wir alle wissen,
je kleiner die Kinder sind, umso
stärker sind sie zu beeinflussen. Und natürlich
ist jeder Lehrer, jede Lehrkraft,
jeder Erzieher, jede Erzieherin bei mir, ist
für die Kinder auch ein Vorbild.
Und ich möchte eben auch verhindern,
dass Kinder klare religiöse
Symbole vor Augen haben und denken: So muss
das sein! Oder so muss das sein.
Sie sollen bei mir an der Schule
die Möglichkeit haben, sich wirklich
frei zu entfalten. Sie müssen die Möglichkeit
haben, bei mir so gebildet, so
erzogen zu werden, dass sie eine ganz klare,
ganz klare Meinungen entwickeln,
ganz klare Standings, selbstbewusste junge
Menschen werden, die sich dann
selbst einer Religion zuordnen oder eben
auch nicht.
-Was befürchtest du, wenn jetzt, wenn du jetzt quasi das Verbot
gibst und sagst: Kommt, macht was ihr wollt,
zieht an, was ihr wollt,
tragt Kreuze oder Kopftücher oder Kippa,
was würde dann passieren?
- Nun, da gibt
es mehrere Dinge, die ich befürchte.
Zum einen befürchte ich,
wenn die die Lehrerinnen, die werden
geliebt, dann sagt so ein kleines Mädchen
zu seiner Mutti zu Hause: Warum trägst
du denn kein Kopftuch, so da muss
die Mutter sich zu Hause erklären?
Und das sind Praxisbeispiele. Ich möchte
den Eltern diese Diskussion nicht
zumuten und ich möchte die Diskussion
in der Schule auch nicht haben. Ich möchte
aber auch nicht die Diskussion haben,
wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Kollegin
mit einem Kopftuch oder einen Kollegen
mit einer Kippa oder einem Kreuz habe,
dass Eltern zu mir sagen: Ich möchte aber,
dass mein Kind jetzt nur noch von der Lehrerin
mit dem Kopftuch oder gar nicht
von der Lehrerin mit dem Kopftuch
unterrichtet wird.
- Dominik, sas klingt doch alles
ganz plausibel und nachvollziehbar.
Warum kommst du nicht vor?
-Nee, das finde ich...
Also, ich bin jetzt wieder zurückgegangen,
weil ich das einen schwierigen Freiheitsbegriff
finde. Natürlich müssen wir diese Diskussion
führen und ich freue mich,
wenn so eine Schule geführt werden.
-Aber ist Schule der Ort dafür?
-Aber warum sollten wir da alles
ausklammern, was den Menschen
zutiefst ausmacht? Und natürlich dürfte
das dann sein, weil man lernt
doch von Haltungen. Und wenn diese Person
ein religiöses Symbol trägt und sich
verfassungskonform verhält, dann ist
das doch perfekt. Und ich, ich, ich.
Du hast vorhin gesagt, du findest religiöse
Menschen immer so wenig
kompromissbereit. Aber die Vorannahmen, die ich da jetzt
gehört habe, da kriege ich einen dicken Hals.
Übergriffig. Als ob ein Kopftuch
oder ein Kreuz sofort übergriffig ist.
Ein Mensch kann übergriffig sein, Worte können
übergriffig sein, aber ein Mensch, der das trägt,
was ihn zutiefst ausmacht
und das auch plausibel erklärt. Zum Beispiel
auch erklärt, warum man Kopftuch
trägt, warum man Kreuze hängen hat,
das hilft doch, Kindern daran zu lernen.
Na ja, aber man muss sicherlich
auch das von Schule zu Schule betrachten.
Meine Schule ist eine Schule, wo wir 49
verschiedene Nationen haben. Da kommen
Menschen aus Kriegsgeieten, die in
diesem Kriegsgebiet Feind waren
und ich finde, dann haben wir als Schule
die Aufgabe, denen auch einen neutralen,
einen sicheren Raum zu schaffen, wo sie ohne die Ängste,
die sie in dem Gebiet,
aus dem sie geflüchtet sind, zu uns
geflüchtet sind, um hier sicher und ruhig
wohnen zu können. Da brauchen Sie diesen geschützten
Raum, um zu lernen. Und es ist
meine Aufgabe, meine Aufgabe als Schulleiter
so einen ganz sicheren,
ganz geschützten Raum zu schaffen, in dem die Kinder
sich frei entfalten können.
In dem Fall kann ich das nachvollziehen
und doch wieder denke ich doch dann hier
die Kinder und den Lehrer begegnen,
der die selbe Religion hat wie die Person,
die sie verfolgt hat, die dafür
Kriege gesorgt hat. Und die merkt: Wow! Und die haben mich
aber lieb, die behandeln mich mit Respekt,
die ermöglichen mir diese Lernräume
und tuen mich nicht anhand
meiner Nation aburteilen. Das ist doch
ein Heilungsprozess. So stelle ich mir
das vor.
-Ich glaube diese Vielfalt
in den Schulen. Deswegen gehe ich noch
mal einen Schritt zurück auf euch zu. Die ist
mir wichtig, die ist mir überall
wichtig. Ich finde, wir leben in einer vielfältigen
Gesellschaft, die durch den Staat
auch repräsentiert werden muss. Nur kann
das nur geschehen, wenn jede
Religion gleichwertig ist. Und wenn wir nicht
nur bei den drei Weltreligionen
bleiben, sondern bei jeder Religion. Und das kann
nur der Staat vertreten, wenn er neutral
bleibt. Das ist so mein Punkt. Du kannst
Vielfalt nicht darstellen, wenn du so
Symbolfiguren aufstellst, wenn du Symbole
an den Schulen aufstellst,
sondern du kannst es nur über Neutralität,
die diese Vielfalt erst ermöglicht.
-Dani, kannst du das nachvollziehen? Du stehst ja
relativ mittig.
-Ich habe mich nach vorne gestellt, weil Carina das Thema
Sicherheit, das emotionale Sicherheit
von Schülern ins Spiel gebracht hat. Das war
ein Punkt, der mir einfach
eingeleuchtet hat. Das ist tatsächlich etwas,
was ich mir nicht überlegt habe und wo ich auch denke,
das muss auch in Anbetracht gezogen werden.
Man müsste auch natürlich
auch das sehr wach beobachten,
wenn man ein Lehrer mit Kippa
auf, auf auf Kinder lässt, die irgendwie
palästinensisch sind, die vielleicht
ganz schlechte Erfahrungen mit Israelis
oder wer auch immer gemacht haben,
dann müsste man das... Aber es ist eben Thema.
Ich möchte nicht, dass der Lehrer seine Kippa
ausziehen möchte, sondern ich möchte,
dass man das an der Schule
dann thematisiert und dass man dann
auch wirklich darüber streitet und dass man
auch spürt, dass diese Wand abgebaut
werden soll. Auf dieser Bühne der Schule
ist die beste Möglichkeit, die Kontraste
und Konflikte und die Unterschiedlichkeiten,
auch die religiösen
Unterschiedlichkeiten voll
auszuleben, voll zu diskutieren. Deswegen bin
ich auch echt gegen eine Neutralitätspflicht.
Ich bin der Meinung,
ich finde, ich wünsche mir Lehrer,
die Haltung haben, die auch eine Haltung
vertreten. Ich wünsche mir
Lehrer, die irgendwie die Schüler fordern,
auch mit einer Meinung, die vielleicht
auch nicht alle haben. Ich habe überhaupt
nichts dagegen. Ich möchte,
dass wir die Kinder frühzeitig erziehen.
Das Leben ist Debatte. Das Leben ist
auch ein Stück weit, eben auch nicht einig sein,
Kompromisse finden müssen,
gemeinsam leben müssen, auch wenn wir ganz,
ganz unterschiedliche Meinungen
haben. Aber das wird eben nicht gelernt durch
Verbote.
-Da muss eine Zwischenfrage stellen an euch:
Was glaubt ihr? Gibt es so
etwas wie Neutralität? Was versteht
ihr darunter? Und glaubt ihr, Menschen
ohne öffentlich getragene religiöse
Symbole sind neutraler als die anderen?
Was ist eure Meinung? Schreibt es gerne
in die Kommentare rein und jetzt ist Fatma
dran.
-Ich komme aus einer kurdischen
Familie, die eigentlich atheistisch ist.
Das war mir lange nicht bewusst. Mir
wurde von mir wurde das geheim gehalten,
weil es innerhalb der Community
ein riesiges Problem gewesen wäre,
wenn ich es ausgeplaudert hätte.
Ich glaube, die Schwierigkeit, die da ist,
ist: Man muss halt auch an die Minderheiten
innerhalb der Minderheiten denken.
Man darf nicht immer alles als ein großes
Kollektiv betrachten. Ich bin als Kurdin
von nicht nur deutschen Rassisten,
sondern oft auch von türkischen Rassisten
betroffen. Also ich glaube, dass eigentlich
in der Schule ein Schutzraum
für alle Mädchen, Frauen, LGBTs haben
will, die fern von, also wirklich kein Kreuz
angucken müssen und an ihre Sünden
denken müssen, wenn sie irgendwie gerade
mit den Gedanken an einen süßen Jungen,
an den sie gerade irgendwie, sechste Klasse
denkt man doch oft an süße Jungen.
Ich möchte nicht, dass das dieser Schutzraum
für die Schutzbedürftigen nicht
vorhanden ist. Und die sind mir in dieser Diskussion
die wichtigsten.
-Du redest eigentlich über negative Religionsfreiheit, aber
auch von Leuten, die vielleicht
tatsächlich religiös sind,
katholisch erzogen wurden, in nicht
Franken, sondern Bayern, aber trotzdem
irgendwie ein schwules Begehren haben
und jedes Mal, wenn sie in der Schule sind,
dieses Kreuz betrachten müssen und davon
sich irgendwie immer wieder bedroht
fühlen.
Ich sehe deinen Punkt auch total, vor allem wenn das geschichtlich betrachtet.
Aber ich finde es gerade gut,
dass ein Kreuz präsent ist, um eben
so eine Fehlwahrnehmung, die voll
auf Tatsachen fußt, die passiert sind.
Das Kreuz
ist nicht "Du bist Süde, du bist
schlecht!", sondern das Kreuz ist, Jesus sagt: Egal wer
du bist, ob du ein Mörder bist, ob du
Unternehmer bist, wer du auch bist, du bist
gleich geliebt in meinen Augen.
Und genau das möchte ich, dass wir
das thematisieren, weil es in Deutschland
halt sonst auch Thema ist. Und dann traue
ich Schülern zu, dass sie auch sich
dazu verhalten können, weil ich als Lehrer es denen
ermögliche.
-Das ist deine Version
des Christentums, wie du sie heute
im wahrscheinlich weitgehend
aufgeklärten Oberfranken, vom Protestantismus her
wahrnimmst. Schauen wir aber an die Quelltexte
der Religionen. Schauen
wir in die gelebte Religion und da will
ich keine Unterschiede machen, dann sieht
das ganz anders aus. Schule ist ein Ort
der Erkenntnis und nicht des Bekenntnis.
Schule ist ein Ort der Aufklärung und nicht
der Verklärung. Und natürlich muss
in der Schule über Religion
gesprochen werden, und zwar massiv. Wer Religion
nicht versteht, versteht die Tagesschau
nicht. Ich finde es super, dass wir hier
darüber streiten und dass wir uns
aufeinander zubewegen. Denn
die Streitkultur ist gerade in den Religionen
offensichtlich sehr schlecht
ausgeprägt.
-Ich finde gerade diese Verdachtshaltung so übergriffig,
wenn ich sage: Ja, du trägst das oder du
bist das! Ziemlich hoher Prozentsatz
bist du deswegen übergriffig oder versuchst
dem Kind etwas aufzudrücken,
was es gar nicht selber will.
-Es geht um Symbole. Es geht nicht um Individuen.
Wenn du der Ansicht bist,
dass Jesus Schwule akzeptiert,
Transpersonen akzeptiert, dann glaube
ich dir das. Aber das Symbol tut es für viele
nicht. Und ich glaube, das ist ja
der Punkt. Wir sprechen hier über Symbole.
Ich bin jemand, der nicht religiös
ist und der auch tatsächlich auch sehr,
sehr wachsam und auch sehr alarmiert
beobachtet. Wie stark die Macht
der Religion ist, wie verantwortlich
auch fundamentalistischer Religion ist, seit
es die Welt gibt. Für sehr, sehr viele
Kriege und sehr, sehr viele Konflikte,
die aus religiösen Gründen geführt
werden. In vielerlei Hinsicht habe ich oft
das Gefühl, dass wir durch das, dass wir in einer Zeit
leben, in dem man sich viel
eher anfängt zu verstecken und man
weiß nicht mal richtig, wo eigentlich
die Positionen sind, sondern die Positionen
werden immer, immer verwoben
und immer eigenartiger. Und du kannst
die Leute gar nicht mehr richtig verorten,
weil die Offenheit und das starke
Bild auch teilweise eben nicht mehr gestattet ist,
weil es eben schon als als als inkorrekt
gilt, in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Und deswegen glaube ich schon, dass das die eine Diskussion
mit der anderen
Diskussion, finde ich, nicht wirklich
nicht viel zu tun. Sondern es geht darum,
dass wir uns alle einig sind. Wir wollen
nicht, dass Religion und Religiosität,
egal welcher Religion, in den zivilrechtlichen
und auch in den sozialen
Rahmen hineinwächst. Manipulativ.
Sondern wir wollen dass, die Religion
ein in sich, ein Kosmos
in sich ist, wo Menschen etwas normal leben
können, was andere gar nicht so
empfinden. Aber ohne sozusagen in den staatlichen
Bereich hinein zu greifen.
-Ich habe noch eine Frage mit dem Blick mal ins Ausland.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Staaten,
die verschiedene andere Regelungen haben.
Es gibt ja zum Beispiel die angloamerikanischen
Staaten, also Amerika,
Kanada, England. Da wird, gibt
es eigentlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit,
dass jeder auch religiöse Symbole auch zum Beispiel
im Polizeidienst tragen kann.
Das Argument dahinter ist zum Beispiel
Wir stellen unsere pluralistische Gesellschaft
dar. Und natürlich gibt es muslimische,
christliche, jüdische oder sonstige
religiöse Menschen, die auch im Polizeidienst
arbeiten. Machen
die das eurer Meinung nach alles
falsch? Reden wir mal über Polizei. Sollten
wir also, sollten Polizistinnen
und Polizisten in Deutschland religiöse
Symbole tragen dürfen? Ja oder nein?
- Nein, auch keine politischen. Ich finde das echt
wichtig, weil gerade die Arbeit
von Polizei und und und Justiz ja
auf Überzeugungen fußen, die sich
quasi im Gegenteil von der Religion abgewendet
haben. Das heißt, England ist auf dem Holzweg.
Ich finde das falsch.
Wie geht es euch? Du sagst, das ist
genau richtig.
-Das ist doch der Ausschluss
letztendlich, sobald ich sage die Menschen...
Meilenweiter Ausschluss.
Die Diskriminierung findet nicht
durch das Gesetz statt, sondern bereits durch
den Islam. Das heißt dadurch, dass ich meine Religion auslebe.
-Nein, es geht
nicht darum, es geht. Es geht
darum, dass die Diskriminierung bereits
da stattfindet, dass Frauen vom Islam
anders behandelt werden als Männer.
Und vor dieser Diskriminierung
schützt sich der deutsche Staat recht gut.
Ich weiß, die Themen sind
miteinander verbunden. Wir können auch ganz klare
Diskussionen dazu führen.
-Da würde ich auch total da stehen.
-Auch das Christentum, Sexismus pur.
Wir haben ja so unsere diversen Jahrhunderte
Erfahrungen mit der Religion. Und wir können heute nur so frei
leben, weil wir uns von der Religion
emanzipiert haben. Ich will weder dir,
noch dir unterstellen, selbst unfrei
zu denken. Aber ich will Verständnis dafür
werben und ich stehe hier ganz
vorne, dass die Betrachtung der Religion
bei Außenstehenden dazu führt, dass wir nicht
den Eindruck bekommen, dass es sich
hierbei um eine liberale Gesinnung
handelt, die Menschen zur Selbstbestimmung
bewegt, das ist das Problem.
-Da stimme ich dir voll ein.
Wenn wir nur Außenwahrnehmung von Dingen,
von Religion in unseren Kindern bieten,
dann ist ihnen nicht geholfen.
Sondern es hilft ihnen exemplarisch zu zeigen:
Wie lebt ein Christ? Es braucht
einen Wahrnehmung, es braucht Menschen
und es kann nicht nur Lernstoff sein.
-Also ich habe mehr und mehr das Gefühl,
dass wir verkennen, dass es hier um gesellschaftlichen
Status geht. Es geht
um das Recht von Staatsbürger*innen,
ihre Religionsfreiheit ausleben zu dürfen.
In dem Moment...
-Lönnen Sie doch!
-Kann ich nicht! Nur nicht als Lehrerin.
Nur nicht als Lehrerin und nicht als Richterin
im Staatsdienst,
als Kassiererin, als Erzieherin im Beruf.
Wo soll ich noch arbeiten? In welchem Bereich?
Wir können uns nicht für Vielfalt
und Pluralität einsetzen, sie dann
ausschließen. Gerade in staatlichen
Institutionen machen wir uns damit
angreifbar. Wir haben
staatliche Institutionen die Diskriminierungen schützen
unsere Bevölkerung nicht davor.
Aber da müssen wir hinschauen.
Ich finde es in der Interaktion mit Dritten
als Person, die vom Staat angestellt ist,
repräsentierst du den Staat. Und ich finde
es sehr komisch, wenn wir jetzt über Leute
nachdenken, die den Staat
repräsentieren und deren Einschränkungen in Gesetzeslagen,
und nicht die Schutzbedürftigen, die dieser Staat
vertritt. Und das ist glaube
ich mein Problem mit dieser ganzen
Diskussion. Es geht doch, es geht
auch um die Schülerinnen. Es geht
doch und es geht auch um die Angeklagten.
Ich gehe gleich wieder ein Schritt zurück,
Da hast Recht.
-Da hast du Recht Fatma, das stimmt schon. Und trotzdem
möchte ich einfach noch mal sagen: Ich bin
überzeugt, es ist kein Weg, dass man
Religion nicht einfach ausleben
und aus ausdrücken darf, frei
ausdrücken darf. Ich glaube, es gibt, es gibt,
es führt nur zu Spaltung. Ich sehe
die Probleme, die wir alle haben,
aber trotzdem ist es nicht. Aber ich bin
nicht der Überzeugung, es ist nicht
der Weg. Ich glaube, der Weg geht zu einer Bekennung.
Zu einem echten Bekennen
dessen, wer man ist.
-Wir werden hier sicherlich keine Lösung finden, aber
ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben ein paar
Gemeinsamkeiten schon herausarbeiten
können. Jetzt versuchen wir noch
mehr Gemeinsamkeiten aufs Feld zu bringen.
Wir nennen es die sogenannte
Kompromissrunde. Ich fange mal mit was ganz
einfachem an. Können wir uns
darauf einigen, dass eine Richterin,
die mit einem auffälligen Kreuz
durch die Gegend läuft, also Christin ist
und das auch zeigt, trotzdem eine neutrale
und gute Richterin sein kann.
Persönlich, nicht dem Gegenüber
gegenüber. Glaubst du nicht? Glaubt ihr?
Ja, du bist nach vorne gegangen, du
bist auch nach vorne.
-Persönlich ja, aber das Gegenüber...
-Ihr könnt auch stehen bleiben.
-Das ist der Punkt.
Wir reden aber erst mal über die Menschen,
die sich vielleicht angegriffen
fühlen, weil sie sagen, weil sie gesagt bekommen
nur weil du ein religiöses Symbol
trägst, glaube ich, halte ich dich nicht mehr
für irgendwie objektiv. Darum geht es.
So, jetzt geht doch bitte mal in euch
in kleinen Gruppen, versucht eine Formulierung
zu finden, wo ihr sagt: Damit
kriegen wir sie rüber. Ziel ist
es ja, möglichst nahe zusammenzukommen.
Kompromissrunde, bitteschön. Ich weiß, es ist
schwer. Aber die Juristin hat eine Idee.
Also ich zum Beispiel
darf auch öffentlich gar keine politische
Forderung stellen. Ich glaube, das ist auch zu kompliziert.
-Was würdet ihr sagen,
was wäre euer Kompromissvorschlag?
Wie kommen diese beiden Seiten noch näher
zusammen, obwohl sie wahrscheinlich
am Ende des Tages nicht den Konsens finden?
Vielleicht finden Sie eine Art Kompromiss.
-Zeigt sie mir nicht, dann dürft ihr mitmachen,
aber solange ihr sie zeigen wollt, dann tut es mir leid.
Ihr könnt angsam zum Schluss kommen,
bitte. Insgesamt steht Grün ein bisschen
weiter vorne als Gelb, also würde ich mal
vorschlagen Grün fängt an, damit
Gelb näher zu euch kommen kann.
Uns ist aufgefallen, dass der Neutralitätsbegriff
offensichtlich ein bisschen Irritationen
hervorruft. Und deswegen war unsere Idee
zu sagen: Wir verstehen die Neutralität,
die wir hier einfordern, die weltanschauliche
eben nicht als ein sich
Raushalten.
-Oder Gleichgültigkeit.
-Oder gar als Gleichgültigkeit oder gar
als Tabuisierung. Sondern wir verlangen,
dass die Institutionen des Staates sich
bekennen zu den Werten von Demokratie
und Aufklärung. Und dann ist es für uns
angezeigt, Symbole, die das konterkarieren,
nicht vor allen Dingen
bei Vertreterinnen dieses Staates zeigen zu lassen.
-Okay, also konnten euch
die Grünen jetzt bewegen, dass ihr euch bewegt?
-Nicht wirklich.
-Das stört mich
massiv und ich glaube, da kann
man nicht weiter: Symbole konterkarieren,
die demokratisch freiheitliche
Grundordnung, das ist so ein Vorurteilsgeladener
Begriff, der unsere, ich kann
Jetzt nur von mir reden, unsere Entwicklung
der Evangelischen Kirche in Deutschland
der letzten 100 Jahre völlig ausblendet.
Und da fühle ich mich absolut nicht gesehen.
-Unser Vorschlag wäre: Ja,
wir gehen davon aus, dass staatliche
Institutionen leider auch diskriminieren.
Da sind wir bei den Schutzbefohlenen
und wir müssen diese Menschen davor schützen.
Da könnte eine Lösung
ein Antidiskriminierungsgesetz sein,
was wir aus Berlin jetzt kennen.
Andere Bundesländer sind da in der Diskussion.
Aktuell haben wir in Deutschland
ein Allgemeines Gleichbehandlungsgesetz.
Das führt dazu, dass man im Berufsleben
oder auch von Privaten nicht diskriminiert
werden darf.
-Mit Ausnahme der Religion, das steht drin.
Die Sache ist die aber, vor staatlichen Institutionen
von der Polizei, in der Schule,
bei der Verwaltung, wenn ich da diskriminiert
werde, bin ich da nicht
geschützt. Und warum sollte ein Staat,
der sich zur Religionsfreiheit
und zur Antidiskriminierungsprinzipien
bekennt, diese nicht auf allen staatlichen
Institutionen sicherstellen?
Eine Lösung wären natürlich die
Antidiskriminierungsgesetze
und ein Bundes-Antidiskriminierungsgesetz,
um unsere staatlichen
Institutionen zu binden. Und gerade
diesen Schutzbefohlenen, die ihr da angebracht
habt, auch zu schützen.
-Das ist zumindest
der Versuch, einen Schritt auf euch
zuzugehen. Zu sagen: Okay, wir sehen,
Schutzräume braucht es auf eure Weise,
wollen sie es nicht, aber auf eine andere
Weise, quasi durch die Hintertür,
ein bisschen mehr tun für schutzbedürftige
Menschen. Da ist der Vorschlag.
-Ich stehe vor allen Dingen deswegen hier so weit
vorne, weil ich, das habe ich eingangs
gesagt, total verstehen kann, dass gerade
Muslime sich ungleich behandelt
fühlen gegenüber der hofierten christlichen
Religion. Bleibe aber dabei, ich finde,
dass der Staat Äquidistanz den selben
Abstand zu allen Religionen haben
sollte. Und das kriegt er am besten hin,
indem er den Kirchen die jetzigen
Privilegien wegnimmt. Denn ansonsten
müssten wir dem Islam und dem Judentum
die gleichen Privilegien geben
wie den Kirchen. Und das halte ich für keine
gute Idee.
Ich war tatsächlich eigentlich sehr glücklich mit der Diskussion.
Ich habe echt gedacht,
bei dem Thema werden wir an zwei
Fronten bleiben und es wird sich nicht viel
bewegt. Aber ich find es war so viel
Bewegung im Raum und mich haben Argumente
überzeugt. Mich haben Argumente
zurück bewegt und ich fand es eigentlich
eine richtig gute Diskussion. Ich fand
es gut, dass wir diese Möglichkeit hatten,
aber an manchen Stellen hatte ich schon
das Gefühl, dass man hier verkennt,
dass es eigentlich hier um einen
gesellschaftlichen Status geht. Es geht
hier auch um mein Recht, als ebenbürtiges,
gleichwertiges Mitglied
in dieser Gesellschaft wahrgenommen
zu werden. Und das wurde mir auch, gerade
in der Debatte über den Safe Space, hat
mir das gefehlt und ich wusste auch gar nicht,
wie ich mich dazu äußern soll. Und ich finde
es gut, dass wir heute darüber
diskutiert haben, dass wir auch auf Augenhöhe
uns begegnen konnten.
Und ich glaube, wir müssen da echt, dass in den Debatten
reinbringen. In der Tat muss
man, glaube ich, noch
stärker darüber reden, was die Symbolik
und die eigentliche Überzeugung der Menschen
miteinander zu tun hat. Ich bin
immer noch der Meinung, dass Institutionen
Schutzräume sein sollten, aber ich habe
es einmal versucht anzubringen. Nicht
die Verpackung des Kopfes zählt in erster
Linie, sondern der Inhalt.
-Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin überrascht,
dass ihr alle relativ weit vorne
steht. Das habe ich vor dieser Folge nicht
erwartet. Ich dachte im Gegenteil,
dass viel mehr Leute ganz hinten stehen
und deswegen Glückwunsch, dass ihr so
kompromissbereit sein. Ich finde es ganz
toll. Natürlich war klar, wir finden
natürlich nicht den einen Konsens heute.
Das ist vollkommen logisch. Aber wir sind
schon relativ nah aufeinander zugegangen.
Wahrscheinlich mehr als es sonst
der Gesellschaft passiert. Vielen Dank dafür.
Danke schön! Hinter
dieser Diskussion und ich denke, das ist heute
klar geworden, steckt ja vor allem
die Frage: In welcher Gesellschaft wollen
wir leben? Wollen wir die Religion
immer weiter zurückdrängen oder wollen
wir sie als selbstverständlichen Teil
von vielen von uns in dieser Gesellschaft
akzeptieren? Wir werden diese Frage
weiterverhandeln. Ich gehe davon aus,
auch im Gerichtssaal. Wenn euch 13
Fragen gefällt, dann könnt ihr hier unseren Kanal
abonnieren. Dort oben findet ihr ein weiteres
13 Fragen Video und hier
ein weiteres Video zum Thema.